les clients de ce restaurant montréalais
n'ont pas regardé à la dépense pour se
faire servir un prestigieux repas 7
service avec de grands vins proposés par
le meilleur sommelier des amériques et
beaucoup de tension dans ce monde
champion en titre est aussi meilleur
sommelier du québec pierre alexis
soulière va représenter le canada dans
quelques jours au concours mondial de la
sommellerie à anvers en belgique
ce serait fou de dire non à une
opportunité comme ça il ya des gens qui
rêvent de ça toute leur carrière c'est
la célébration d'un métier de l'amour
divin mais il ne sera pas tout seul en
face il y aura 65 candidats dont un
autre québécois carl villeneuve lepage
qui lui en oeuvre ou restaurant toqué
juste de participer à des concours à
quelque chose de plaisant dans le fait
de voyager aussi du niveau de stress
quand même assez intense
on sait à peu près qu'est-ce que les
autres vivent bon sans qu'on crie puis
ça crée une belle communauté
cela fait des mois que les deux hommes
dans la jeune trentaine s'entraîne tous
les jours chacun de leur côté
c'était juste pour voir sur quels
cépages allait atterrir c'est un merlot
de roumanie c'est pas comme si on avait
d ailleurs même moment donné on a une
façon de travailler peut-être qu'ils
aient besoin d'être commentées pour
étendre je pense le champ de vision pour
le métier de sommeil n'est pas que de
déguster des vins n'est pas que de
d'apprendre des villages ou des terroirs
où des sols ou le long d'un chien d'un
producteur c'est aussi des histoires
c'est des gens elle ne songe au
graphique elle ne sont historiques et
nation sociologique avec les gens et
puis aussi de procurer du plaisir aux
clients comme pour tout athlète ses
champions aux papilles olympiques sont
suivies par des psychologues pour se
préparer au stress de la compétition
c'est un espèce de d'aspirateurs
d'énergie c'est un moment d'attenté
parce qu'on pense à ce qu'on a déjà fait
ça fait là nos têtes on appréhende
peut-être qu est ce qui s'en vient c'est
ça fait battre car beaucoup trop vite
pour être assis en train d'attendre
après véronique rivet et élyse lambert
ce sont encore des québécois qui
défendent les couleurs du canada mais
pourquoi le québec est il devenu un
leader en sommellerie
les écoles ont formé beaucoup de gens à
l expertise du vin à la saq est beaucoup
d écoles dans le sens où la saq propose
un grand nombre de produits plus un
grand nombre d' agences privées on a
vingt mille produits disponibles au
québec c'est gigantesque
ce qui permet aux étudiants aux
professionnels de se former de connaître
les vins du monde entier
peu importe que le résultat au concours
mondial
qu'arrivera-t-il ensuite on veut tous
les deux gagner et puis cet angle qui
est le véritable gagnant là demain c'est
la sommellerie québécoise la sommellerie
canadienne qui a réussi à faire grandir
de personnes qui vont représenter le
pays
la suite à partir du 10 mars à anvers
ici frédéric arnould